yeah oh i've seen him he's worked out
with my uh
friend before oh look at him as a little
boy dude oh he's bullied
he's been at it for a while now in
person because there's he's one of the
most hotly requested like everybody will
do these videos on whether he's natty or
not
this is not something i think about a
lot but in person
you know i think you see this like the
lighting and the this and that he looks
more shredded and sort of more unnatural
in these photos but in person
he doesn't like to me he looks like he's
not achievable yeah
but again he's been added for so many
years his diet's impeccable you can see
how
you know he's super low
i don't want to be that big though like
i don't want to be like no wait but
like you said you wanted to gain 40
pounds last time i saw you
yeah but like that like over like a year
like not like falling out
you'd have to call the rock and say take
the wheel yeah
yeah you would have to eat more trend
in a year it might be a very unrealistic
goal okay then
however long it takes then i don't
really know like but he's gonna start
going away
this is hard to gain that weight oh my
god what about what about 20.
20 in a year yeah but also this is going
back to the hollywood thing that we said
before
we have this idea of 20 pounds of muscle
no the only real way to tell that like
you could
if you see a bodybuilder on stage and
he's at a certain body fat percentage
you can be like and
five years later he gained this much
stage weight because otherwise it's like
you can gain 20 pounds this weekend is
it all muscle yeah no
you could you could retain water you
could even take you know we talked about
certain anabolics will make you gain a
bunch of
water and it enhances your strength but
it's not real muscle
you don't even it's not actual like that
when you take creatine monohydrate you
put on five pounds yeah
so we're not making there's nothing you
do it's just five pounds of muscle in a
week yeah
it just so mark what would be a
realistic goal for me for like in a year
five pounds no but i fluctuate like five
pounds like five like i said five pounds
of real lean muscles oh um
five to ten pounds on the high end um
of like yeah at the same hydration level
in a year in a year yeah but again it
doesn't sound like a lot because
you we have these hollywood standards of
like
in three months i gained 25 pounds of
muscle while dropping six percent of my
body fat which is
it's just a lie and it's impossible and
you can make aesthetic changes but
if you were to really look at how much
muscle somebody gained by looking at
their exact same
like body fat and hydration levels you
know what i mean if you stayed at 10
body fat
and you were the same level but for him
let's say you put on 10 pounds of muscle
right
i'll say it's not going to be straight
that there's going to be 10 pounds of
muscle but then you're also going to put
probably other weight on yourself as
long as i look good i'm okay with that
if i put it on a little extra weight
dude you need to hang out with that
17 year old freaking i showed you with
those leaf legs
and all this [ __ ] bro if stevie don't
work out come to the gym
stephen you know i love you listen i
don't know his personality is i don't
think it's great
to be honest okay he seems really nice
but you know
i don't think he's gonna get us to mars
he's so in his own when he works out
yeah
he's so in his own life so how tall is
this kid
five five five five okay what are you
five five five five yeah he's probably
around there you guys would be so cute
together cat i mean
two tiny asian couple two tiny asians
he looks kind of mixed no i don't think
he's like a little mix
what'd you what'd you say chin i said oh
gosh five three no he's not five three
ah he's short man i said he's sure but i
don't think he's five three dude him and
a squad
there's not one so i call him the short
game yeah not literally the short kings
are they they're i think they're all
asian-ish like they're mixed
one of those not one over five five yeah
and they're just like
i think one of them is his brother makes
sense he's like his film guy
and there's another guy that looks like
him that i don't necessarily see he
looks like
but then there's one guy who's uh he's
built like uh
one of those little uh schnauzer dogs
little little legs
his little legs and a big body but he's
still like by four feet
his legs
but they're cool man